hello everyone this is amir from audio
science review i have another debunking
video for you
it's a difficult topic to address it's
uh
a couple of papers that have come out
with from professor kuncher
from south carolina university and
uh
normally it wouldn't be anything worth
your time to worry about except couple
of youtubers have
latched under these papers
and
here you see jay yucky's uh youtube
channel
where he positions this thing as proof
that there are measurable uh differences
in audio interconnect cables and that we
can now objectively prove that there
there's audible differences between
cables it's a funny thing because we
absolutely can measure differences
between cables the question is do those
measurements matter
uh as far as perception
and
and the short answers they don't but uh
i originally didn't mean to address this
uh uh paper because it's just too much
work to try to get into it but multiple
people have reached out to me and asked
me about the these youtube videos and
and what people are saying about them so
i thought i'd go ahead and do a um
breakdown of of the papers uh professor
cuncher has done actually three papers
one that came out a few years ago and
had very classic mistakes in it claiming
that digital audio resolution is uh
timing resolution is depending on his
sample rate which is just patently wrong
and then a few years went by and he uh
produced a new paper um which i'm not
addressing here because it turns out
that he actually addresses it himself
and that paper came out last year and
and was published in aes and it was
phrased as cable pathways between audio
components can affect that perceived
sound quality and what he did was that
he took a dac and and an amplifier and
connected both xlr and rca connections
to the amplifier and then a b switched
the amplifier between the balance input
and unbalance input the implication of
the whole paper
is that he's showing the differences
between the two cables
but in reality first the two cables are
one is a balanced xlr the other one's
rca but more importantly the dac and
amplifiers have unknown
transfer functions frequency response
noise and distortions between their
balance uh interconnects and rca so no
way can you conclude whatever you're
measuring out of this a b testing that
is relatable to the cable itself could
very well be that the xlr connection had
wider bandwidth or the rca won't add
more noise or what have you
and so i and many other people objected
to this and pointed out all these
problems and
unfortunately the author starts with his
newest paper acknowledging that this
problem exists so the introduction
and you can see the link to the paper
here
he goes in there and then he admits at
the end says however that approach
prevented distinguish between noise
between the pathways original from
balance versus unbalance or the cables
themselves
excuse me hallelujah that's
that's that's one of the many problems
of the paper
with the first paper so
it's good that he's acknowledged this
and but it's sad that the aes
published this uh after peer review in
in the journal so that was a mistake on
multiple fronts
so we now get into the second paper
or the third paper in sequence and the
one that you know youtubers are jumping
on and what i'm going to do
is to
code sections of it and the paper is
divided into different sections it's
only measurements there's no listening
tests in this paper the last one i have
listening test this one does not have
any listening test there's purely
measurements so any claims about
audibility is just claims it's not
backed by any listening test in this
final third paper and uh what he does is
that he uh
uh
tries to attack the problem of
measurements from multiple vectors and
that's a good approach
and he actually says some of them are
dead ends and so what i'm going to do is
that i'm going to talk about each
section so in the introduction of what
cables is testing
he says there are three different cables
one is a premium cable
one is a sort of a premium cable and one
is a generic freebie one and i'll give
you more details about this as he
mentions them later on um and he implies
that you when you go shopping for the
cables you have these three distinct
categories but as you probably guys know
that there is no such uh um there's no
such grades in the audio cables there's
no certification and
i can buy a five dollar
cable that could be fantastic as far as
bandwidth and performance and i could
buy a fifty thousand dollar cable that
would be horrific from a point of view
of performance so uh the notion that
he's just gonna tell us that these are
three generic categories and and let's
run with them it just doesn't make any
sense doesn't even pass common sense
it's a minimum you should tell us what
these cables are so that we can go and
replicate his measurements and testing
he doesn't even tell us what these
brands are the model nothing he just
said
we picked three cables and one is you
know uh high the other one is mid and
the final one is a gp freebie one it's
like well
you know what kind of science is this
you know when we can't even go replicate
it would have taken nothing for him to
mention these uh cables and and but he
does not
okay
so let's get into them um the section
2.1
defines it sort of says oh let's treat
audio as a low frequency problem and low
frequency defines up to one megahertz
well hearing stops at 20 kilohertz so
one mega is just very high bandwidth for
audio you've already gone way past
anything reasonable uh there's no
nothing that can hear one megas or
anything like that those are radio
frequencies and am radios so
that doesn't make any sense itself
fortunately he concludes that even if we
go up to one megahertz um that
you know if we measure sort of the
losses and and things like skin effect
they're at
zero .001 db difference so therefore
this doesn't matter so it's like
hallelujah yeah that's that's good and
the paper should have really stopped
here there's nothing past this point if
up to one megahertz we can't quantify
anything uh being a problem then we're
done on this thing but
this is just warm-up act it goes from
here
so
um then he gets into this notion that
i've never ever seen and he invents it
and he just runs with it throughout the
paper
there's this
implication that every cable has
capacitance which it does
anything anytime you have a conductor an
insulator um you can get
an another conductor you can get a
very small capacitor it gets formed in
there we can hold the charge
but he claims that this capacitor is
instantly
changing its charge going from max to
minimum or zero to max this is just
observed no capacitor does this
capacitors take time to charge and take
time to discharge audio signals are
extremely slow in in the world of of you
know uh
frequencies as if we can go to many many
gigahertz and and higher and we're
talking 20 kilohertz maximum what we can
hear and so nothing is changing fast in
in in audio world to say that the
capacitance of the of the
cable is instantly changing therefore we
should go measure those instant effects
just assumption is just totally totally
totally wrong
nothing in your audio system would work
if this assumption is true
because we have much larger capacitors
inside your amplifiers and and
everything else if those are instantly
charging and discharging well then help
break should lose you know nothing would
ever work in electronics if that was the
case so it's just the whole concept is
ridiculous and again we could stop here
but for the sake of completeness and for
you referencing it in the future
somebody jumps on these things and tries
to uh you know challenge you you have
this presentation to go back to okay
so um
let's talk about where these things
matter
there's this word transmission line is
thrown around throughout much of the
paper
the transmission line comes about if
the signal is changing so fast or the
length of the transmission is so long
that that
that the waveforms for current and
voltage start to get out of sync and as
they do the effective impedance changes
along the length of the cable that
complicates the heck out of these our
world and indeed anybody designing radio
frequency equipment has to deal with
this day gun it's a world to itself
people say there's combination of
science and art is it's so difficult at
times to design things that go up to you
know gigahertz and higher frequencies
but even in many megahertz they can be
very challenging
fortunately
the if you
look at when you have to apply this
it there's some nice rule of thumb and
where do you get this rule of thumb you
go to the d expert
in the world of electromagnetic
interference and compatibility and
transmission it's a book by henry art
henry it's just is i don't want to say
it's the icing of this world but he's
the gold reference authority on this and
if you want to learn anything about emi
and electromagnetic interference and so
forth get this book as i have and in
there he has this very clear rule that
all engineers know about is that
the only worry about it this
transmission line effects is when the
length of the wire is more than
one-tenth of the wavelength of of the
frequency that you're dealing with so if
we apply this to audio and we use the
highest audio frequency we can hear is
20 kilohertz that means transmission
line effects only happen at one tenth of
this number the wavelength and
that's
1500 meters so 1.5 kilometers or
before we have to treat audio as a
transmission line that's why the phone
company in the old days when
we use wired phone lines when i go from
city to city yes you worry about
transmission line effects even for voice
transmission uh but you know in our
world with you know one meter
interconnect cable where 1500 times
below this when this effect even starts
to become significant so any talk about
transmission line effects for audio
cables interconnect cables or any kind
of audio capable it just makes zero zero
sense it immediately is a red flag
saying whoever's saying this doesn't
have a foggish notion of what they're
talking about go talk to any rf
engineers any serious engineer they'll
tell you this thing they'll laugh at you
so when you say uh audio cable is a
transmission line it simply is not
if you transmit digital audio over it
those pulses are sharp and i'll talk
about that then the bandwidth gets
higher but for analog audio
it absolutely doesn't matter and you can
go up to 20 kilohertz to any frequency
you want 100 kilohertz and you still
can't get to anything close to these
kind of things and that's a great thing
because if you open up an audio
amplifier or audio dac it has nothing in
there that is designed based on these
principles whereas if you open an fm
transmitter or you know your cell phone
the rf section of that you'll see all
kinds of tricks and how even the
smallest line or pc board trace is
meticulously designed and drawn and
if you just like touch that trace
everything stops working whereas i can
touch an audio amplifier you know inside
and nothing will happen will just work
just as well as it did
before that so
again we could stop here and say
everything is going to talk about is
observed but let's go through the
practice of of looking at the kind of
testing he does so you're educated when
people try to pull stunt like this on
you
so and uh here he not only talks about
these transmission line effects
mattering but he also talks about oh
these effects are non-linear therefore
very complicated and so forth and then
we got some really absurd stuff he says
look he can deal with some of these
issues uh by having uh by using ordinary
you know rg59 cables or you could go buy
this two or three thousand dollar
nordust uh norse 2 cable it's like what
who writes a paper like this where you
mix a proper reference like you know a
cable with a certain interconnect
certain geometry two also a nordos norse
2 cable really i've got to have make a
reference to a
you know
put this in the same sentence of these
things it just makes no sense and this
section by the way it deals with this
whole notion of propagation speed
through a cable how close that is to
speed of light which is what the c is
and this whole thing is just a complete
bunk um there's a company called
iconoclast a spin-off of a guy left by
belden cable
and makes this cables called the icono
class i did a complete review
measurements and a music null test where
i show what the difference is between
data and a dirt cheap
junk cable and null test showed with
real music content there is absolutely
nothing that this cable brings to the
table even though it follows this whole
assumption of you know propagation speed
matters to a cable where you know not
being exactly at speed of light but a
little bit below speed of light and high
can vary from 20 hairspray 20 kilohertz
it goes a hair slower or faster uh that
can change the the sound well no i've
got not only is this whole concept makes
no sense but again i have done an exact
review of a cable far more than the nord
nordust norse 2 that is its entire focus
around this thing and i showed that with
whether you look at the suit absolute
measurements or
null tests of real music it makes no
difference whatsoever
then there's this whole notion that uh
you know he says oh in the last paper we
proved that noise is what impacted what
people were hearing that's totally
nonsense when you do an a b test like
you did with between xlr and rca cables
and some people you know thought one
sounded better than the other
that's not a cause and effect that's an
observation
you then you can't just say well i also
measured the noise was a little bit
higher and one versus the other
no that doesn't mean the two are
connected together if you think noise is
the problem you generate noise and you
vary the amount of noise and see if that
is the controllable parameter
in there and by the way noise is noise
you either hear it or don't hear it you
don't get this thing about this
imaginary you know sound stage changing
or you know the highs also sound this
way or that way and ironically more
noise can actually improve the
perception of detail and because it it
actually adds a sparkle to amount of to
the high frequencies and makes it more
brilliant
and so like those of you photographers
may know this that the film grain uh in
the old days when we used to show them
film if you remove that grain oftentimes
the image actually will look softer
because that randomness that sparkle
actually made people think the image is
sharper and better not that it's worse
so his old assumption that more noise is
worse is kind of absurd anyway but again
there was no cause and effect whatsoever
in his original paper it's just him all
of a sudden connects the two together so
here's some random
invalid measurement about noise and
therefore that is the reason
maybe people prefer this to that so
please don't fall for this whole section
2.4
so he now gets into section 3.1 gets
into the cables again and he says the
first one is a 500 audio file
interconnect
which one we don't know it gets into
what is material is like whoopty dude
why do i care about that show me the
specifications for that cable show me
the measurements of that cable show me
who made it what it was not that it's
500
the next one is a 50 one and it happened
to be one of the ones where it's
grounded at one end versus the other so
it's directional and and then the third
one is some kind of generic
cable you buy from a general store for
five dollars
really there's these three buckets i had
no idea that there was the world had
standardized on these three buckets i
could go get you know a sample of 10 of
these freebie cables and they would all
have different characteristics because
this one was constructed differently
different material different cabling and
for ten dollars you can get a video
cable has incredibly good bandwidth and
good termination and everything or you
can get a you know literally a crappy
cable that's got the thinnest conductors
known to man and be different but both
of them could still be five or ten
dollars you can't assume these three
categories are like this but he
basically says the price is a
determinant of these three rankings
which as you guys know that watched my
game videos and understand this fail
price means nothing is what somebody
decided to charge for a cable uh what
matters the specifications of these
cables which it doesn't give us he
doesn't tell us the cable brands because
i was more than happy to go ahead and
replicate all of his tasks don't realize
he hasn't identified anything i can't go
what fifty dollar cable what 500 cable
so it shows you this observed bias he
has and by the way he's a high-end audio
file and he keeps dragging the student
into his day job his deja he's a physics
and astrophysics a professor it's
nothing to do with audio
and
he keeps wanting to use his everyday job
to try to justify and do research on
audio uh high-end audio prove that
high-end audio has value so and it shows
in here where he thinks more money means
more quality
anyway he also picked a two meter
interconnect cable six feet
you know i used two meter cables too for
ease of testing here but a lot of you
probably using one meter cable and and
the kind of testing is going to do this
length matters so why not test the one
meter cable you know interconnects
usually you're not going six feet apart
you have your amplifier preamble deck
pretty close together most people are
not dangling a six foot cable a two
meter cable between them so this is
another bias where it's trying to do
this and and i sort of implied later
that these cables actually weren't even
the same length because he says it's
compensated some of the parameters
it they normalize them to length which
to me would be even more absurd if he
hasn't matched the cable links
excuse me
so
um
then he starts this whole section and
saying oh you know you don't want to use
re room eq wizard and audio interface to
do this kind of testing it's like whoa
where did that come from once you get an
audio analyzer like i have that's how
you do testing or proper equipment who's
using you know ruby key wizard and a
sound card but even if you did that's
perfectly fine 190 kilo sampling rate
gives you 96 kilos bandwidth for audio
is you know four and a half times more
than you're hearing grace is perfectly
fine um but he goes out and says hey
look what you really want to use is a
digital storage scope that goes up to 10
gigahertz single shot capture
like really 10 gigahertz
oscilloscope we need to measure uh 20
kilos so we have 20 kilohertz thousand
times more than that is 20 megahertz
thousand times more than that is two
gigs or 20 gigahertz so he's going a
million times higher bandwidth he thinks
we need to measure the uh
an audio cable it's like where does that
come from by the way my measurements are
done as most of you know with audio
precision analyzer it can go up to
megahertz bandwidth which is plenty for
audio 25 times more than the bandwidth
and importantly it outperforms all these
fancy soundings equipment is throwing at
you because it has 24-bit analog digital
converters
and whereas these digital scopes have
8-10 bit
adc they also digitize the signal before
analyzing it but because they have to
run at such high speed you can't keep
accuracy and a bit depth high so the
dynamic range of these scopes is quite
poor so
whenever you give it a chance you want
to measure something with the least
amount of bandwidth when appropriate too
so i'm able to dig way deeper in noise
floor and distortion with my analyzer
than you ever can do with this now if
you're measuring cellular you know
transmitting inside a cell phone and
runs two and a half gigahertz whatever
then you have to use this kind of uh
scope and that's the you know and you
give up dynamic range but fortunately
for rf work you don't need that kind of
dynamic range um
but uh you know he brags about this
thing and and uh hoping to confuse
people
like you know typical youtuber who just
sees it so whoa wow that's really fancy
there for this there's a big deal it's
like no he's gone to the university lab
and
grabbed the 10 gigahertz scope and said
let's use that to analyze things like no
no
you're using the wrong tool for the job
but i'll show later on how he's arrived
at the wrong data because that's what
he's done
so he just quickly says look we've taken
the cables and hooked them up between a
signal generator and the scope
wait a second these are rca cables is
testing look on the this is the exact
picture of the scope that they're using
and here's a 204 lxi from the coroi and
look they have bnc connectors every
scope out there has a bnc connectors
none have an rca connector rca
connectors is the wrong kind of
connector for rf work and radio
frequency or high frequency work and
it's not a proper
interface to use so how did you hook up
an rca cable to this you said well you
can go buy little adapters well you can
but that adapter at high frequencies can
actually have impedance mismatch and
cause reflections of its own so while at
audio rates it would not matter and i
use the same thing on my audio analyzer
as bnc instead of rca but if you're
going to go test things at rf then you
better then make sure that you use a
proper rgbnc adapter and that you
include that effect and subtract it from
what you're measuring because you you
could very well just be measuring the
interface uh
problem and the adapter versus the cable
the cable could be quite innocent and
you heard so these are the sort of red
marks that the red flags that i see as i
read this paper and say whoa whoa here's
somebody who actually doesn't know
anything about what he's doing in here
because no engineer doing rf work will
try to take an rga cable and hook up it
to b and c and then hook it up again on
the other end same way and claim to be
making very high frequency measurements
and
on this thing so
be very very careful on this thing that
this kind of testing is just not valid
and you know it's a lot of hand waving
going on
so
he goes in here and and this one is done
with a simple lcr meter which is
measures resistance inductance and
capacitance of a cable and he dumps
these numbers
and
uh
first thing he does which is the good
thing is by the way if you just look at
the resistance of the cable and then it
computes it as a power rating with the
units i've never seen of us
he creates this micro b
uh scale of
0.0001 db
when he uses that he can then claim
these single digit numbers in decimal
but in reality if this 4.11
is actually
0.0004.1
in here so this is an exceptionally
small number uh these the the power
losses over this uh
two meter cable which is of course true
because the the resistance of it is only
47 million
thousandths of an oh there's just the
resistance is not a problem in the
interconnect cable thankfully comes to
his own sense and says oh yeah for this
thing to matter get a
three db loss it has to be 11 kilometers
long
of course it has to be that long to
matter so
he dismisses that resistance is an issue
but then he jumps on this whole
transmission line effect and he says hey
looky over here and he creates this
delta z percentage which i haven't seen
and he claims a look you know as i go
from expensive cable to a cheap cable
it things progressively get worse in
this delta z percentage which i think is
based on his uh
propagation speed or some other silly
thing like this and
therefore this is this is a better cable
it's like no that's just a simple
formula that he applies and it's only
true when you're entering in
transmission line effects and again i
could go pick a another free cable and
comp and have it blow away his fancy
cable and i'm also putting aside that
these measurements are correct measuring
these small values correctly and
everything requires real skill even
things like how you terminate the ends
how do you connect an lcl meter to an
rca cable you know
the connections don't fit each other so
how you attach one just the ending of it
you know how you attach that how much
torque you even put on it has you know
how tight you make those connections
wildly changes this thing it's certainly
not work for a beginner to just jump in
there so we go to engineering lab get an
lcr meter and hook up the 6-foot cable
how you even lay that cable if you don't
have it completely flat and identical
when i did a cable test with the
speaker cable i lay them perfectly in
the exact same position on the table so
they're all measured exactly the same
you coil the cable or throw it around
they can pick up interference from the
air am stations and others and they can
change the induction and capacitance
just because the way you've laid them so
i don't take any of this to be correct
anyway and and but even if we did it's
like whoop to do there is no such delta
z percentage of these numbers in here to
matter whatsoever
okay
excuse me so
um then he goes does another test in
here with 600 megahertz bandwidth
testing
600 mega 500 megahertz bandwidth
we're not even at 500 kilohertz for
audio and you jump into 500 megahertz
measurement of this thing but then
luckily says yeah the amplitude in the
frequency response variation that they
measured
was only 0.03 db
and therefore
the tonality cannot change so it says
when people on an audio form says the
cables can be frequently responsive
cause that's wrong
but then he goes and invents this thing
called the subjective frequency response
that is the timbre or tonal quality of
the sound through other
factors investigated here like really
there's a subjective frequency response
who the heck invented this i mean this
makes no sense to me you don't get to
invent it there's a frequency response
that's imagined and it's called
subjective just throw it out there and
say let's assume this is a fact and let
me now prove it to you through the
following test so let's say his
following test
what is his following test he says all
right let's
get a signal generated that's a pulse
generator what's a pulse generator
because it
generates these very precise uh square
waves where you go
and comes back down
and he says let's have it generate five
volt pulses
and that uh
um let's see the uh uh you know i'll get
into the frequency of it in a second but
it's like
analog audio it's changing gradually
it's not a
pulse and it certainly doesn't jump from
zero to five volts and back to zero
that becomes a very high frequency
signal and yes you better have proper
cables and a proper cable is not an rca
cable or iron audio cable it's a bnc rf
cable that you get that you connect you
don't use rca cables and and
rig the stuff to do this okay
so what pulses is he generating that he
sets the pulses to be 4 nanoseconds
narrowest possible pulse
4 nanosecond is 250 megs you just invert
that 1 over 4 nanoseconds and you get
the frequency
he's measuring 250 megahertz
pulses there that that kind of bandwidth
they're going through this audio cable
and then it says if we measure that we
see that oh yeah the three cables are
ranked order again the cheapest one is
is
that this kind of rise time or or
latency or whatever heck he's calling in
here i think he's he thinks it's a
velocity through the cable propagation
and one you see here the other one's
here and the other one is here therefore
it proves that the uh this one's a
better cable than this one it's like
again i can pick any you know much
different budget cables and have it
produce something else but why would i
care about a
four nanosecond pulse to go do anything
this cable will never ever in audio
applications be subjected to a four
nanosecond pulse
okay
so
yes everything matters if you do have a
490 second pulse a lot of things matter
and all three of these cables will be
trash for you know doing something like
that um
and uh but for audio we don't do that
and by the way proof point is try to
push that four nanosecond pulse through
your audio equipment or your speakers
you think what comes out is a four
nanosecond pulse no it will be
obliterated to be nothing coming out of
the the system and if the rest of the
equipment doesn't care and will do all
these crazy things in the velocity speed
then what difference does it make what
the interconnect cable is doing the
interconnect cable actually has got the
widest bandwidth of anything between
your audio cable uh interconnect cable
can go to many megahertz uh easily but
your amplifier can't go too many makers
easily so
why would it matter what this cable is
doing between two pieces of audio coupon
but what's inside your speakers and
those crossovers and those wires and all
that stuff none of that matters you know
the circuit board traces it you know the
velocity propagation speed through those
things don't matter but it matters in
the cable itself it's just quite
observed
okay then it gets into this noise thing
that's just boggles the mind but
he
okay so he goes back to one mega
bandwidth and
without specifying whatsoever how these
cables are laid what the environment is
how noise sources are controlled or
anything he says let's measure the noise
not just an absolute level but measure
the noise in the
left and the right
and see how they correlated together
because depending on the correlated they
sound different it's like no if the
noise is exceptionally low you can't
even hear it and if the noise above
audible band you also can't hear it i
don't care if there's interference going
into the cable at 200 killers that goes
into left and right the same way that
has nothing to do with audibility of
correlated uh signals versus you know in
let's say music which tells us channel
separation and sound staging when it's
real audio frequencies not way to heck
out out of bed
so let's see the measurements he does
he does this shows his fft again these
are the three cable the s and m and g
and you know at least here nicely says
this is the 20 kilohertz limit
that he shows the spectrum of
junk really he's
he's saying these things are the noises
these things picked up
you know in here it says this is micro
volts 10 micro volts that's huge amount
of noise pickup this is all garbage
interference
and noises in the source or the f the
analyzer because he's not using proper
audio equipment i've tested one of these
free cables throwaway cables and i did a
video on it and this is my measurement
of that where that cable is transmitting
one kilohertz tone which is this and
look at the only thing that's visible in
here is actually the distortion from the
audio analyzer itself at minus 150
decibels it's down to nano volts over
here look at how clean this is there's
not a single all these spikes is showing
in here up to 20 kilohertz they would be
up this high over here and you don't see
a single thing in here whatsoever my
largest spike in here is a mains noise
at 60 hertz which is minus 150 db
so
clean up your measurements you don't go
measuring noise like this and
just this stuff is just garbage i mean
who knows maybe it's got fluorescent led
lights that are just interfering with
these cables again you have to
you know have all the cables be parallel
and properly set up and you know how you
couple the ends matters again you go
from rca to bnc you screw things up so
total total junk science in here junk
everything just mind-boggling that
nobody proper they don't understand the
basics of this thing look it says what
the hell is this garbage you're showing
and by the way he says this is the best
and this is the next best and this is
the worst well that's not how it looks
to be look at this medium cable is
really far worse than this cheaper cable
so that screws up this thing and by the
way amc you know which which one of them
looks better i don't know both of them
look bad and uh
there's nothing distinguishing this 500
cable from this you know free five
dollar one so based on his own things
this is wrong too
so
um this is his summary not my summary am
i somebody next so he says that noise is
available at audible levels yeah if the
noise is you know one micro volts
depending on how much amplified would be
audible level but you you measured it
wrong this is the actual noise there's
nothing there and you know
go ahead and hook up it normally you
know connect to your system are you
hearing hiss and noise because of the
cable no you're hearing his noise
because your amplifier is making noise
if your speakers are very sensitive your
headphones are very sensitive so this is
just observed there's nothing
even supported in the paper there's
anything audible in here you can't just
wave your hand and say this uh on this
thing and again i've measured tons and
tons of equipment and uh
every dac and preamp everything i
measure is using an amazon basics cable
which i think is a 10 cable goes through
my analyzer and i show that the
instrument whatever i'm measuring plus
the instruments noise plus the
interconnect noise is a thousand times
lower than what he's measuring
so clearly is this is measurement errors
in there
and but let's say we take the
what he's saying
he's saying look uh because there's an
order in here that the cheaper and the
better and the most expensive
when i measured certain things certain
way these parameters
were in sync with that price difference
it's like whoop they do
what does that mean you know it's not
like you want to test the 10k cheap
cables or phantom model to be performing
the same
cables are different it's all you know
depends on what choices you made who
knows if you picked different cables and
got different results and you played
with them enough to get what you want
okay so
and uh
a lot of these things by the way even
though it's put in the summary it says
you know signal dagger there's a
tribal electric noise effect all these
things are in the summary there's
nothing in the paper about any of the
stuff microphonic aspects of the cable
that's not in the paper it's not
measured whatsoever what the heck are
these things doing in the summary if you
don't summarize something you don't
introduce new topics at the end
so
he's he he continues and he says oh
prior work demonstrated audibility of of
these things and that that was because
rf noise was the likely cause of the
difference people perceived rf noise
then again no there was no cause and
effect in his previous study and
no way was rf noise to proven to be
the cause of anything in there it was
just something he measured some rf noise
and claim this lower and one versus the
other whoop they do that's not the
reason for any audibility difference in
in a b testing
but
and yes at high frequencies cables
become extremely important the
interconnects terminations everything
becomes important but audio is not high
frequency audio is just
you know very close to dc
so what is my summary if you didn't
understand any of that that's okay
just when somebody says oh check out
this scientific proof the answer should
be
there's nothing there he's saying that's
the saying goes it's a nothing burger
he the handful of measurements are
performed that they sound fancy because
i use this scope and that thing and
here's a bunch of formulas and
everything the measurements are trivial
they show that the author doesn't
understand the tools he's using doesn't
understand the topic
yes he has a phd in physics and
astrophysics i'm sure he could write
papers in that domain that i wouldn't
have will be able to even understand
what he's talking about but this is my
domain that of engineering this is what
i understand this is what many engineers
understand and they would just laugh at
what he's trying to do he's just talks
about and writes things in a way that
clearly indicates he went borrowed bunch
of electronic things from the
engineering lab and made some
measurements
but he should have talked to the
engineers in that department and the
professors there and say hey what do you
think of what i'm doing in here and that
would have schooled them well so
lots of lots of warning flags that what
he's doing is going outside his field of
expertise and he's no different than a
hobbyist with access to some gear in the
university lab
and uh
he claims there's some timing effects
with three random cables again you want
you want to prove that great give me the
brands and models i'll go ahead and
retest them properly let's see even if
your measurements are correct let alone
the conclusions you draw on them and
what effect he does show these three
random cables is that you know mega
errors and gigahertz which we absolutely
do not care about
he then makes random connections to
audible fact none of that is in the
paper the paper is just about
measurements this bunch of references oh
here's reference number 35 says what i'm
saying is here's true it's like no
absurd nonsense you know you want to say
there's some audible go ahead and show
me the psychoacoustic analysis of uh you
know four nanosecond pulse you know how
is that you know what what aspects of
that is audible on and what
and please please don't think there's
signs here there's research here there's
nothing in there there's no signs in
here there's no research in here this is
just bunch of
uh hobbyist level measurements as i
mentioned of a few parameters of of
cable to say hey can we find a
difference
yeah you don't even need to do any of
this stuff i show measurement
differences even in you know well below
makers we can show differences in the
cables the question is where do they
land are they audible and by the way is
it in favor of the expensive cables no
many times i measure uh these cables
find that it's the expensive cable that
picks up more noise picks up more
interference not the cheap one so
bottom line
you know it's just there's nothing there
anybody who throws that youtube at you
or that paper just point them at this
thing and say if you don't understand
it's the video i just did then stop
don't believe stuff just because you
like the you know punch line that's
thrown at you
okay
hopefully yeah you handle this 41 minute
video it's a lot of work putting this
analysis together but i thought i'd do
it once and shoot a video okay see you
in a future one bye